ก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
แล้วกลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนเราเหมือนเดิม
ใช่แล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวไปเจออ่ะขอบคุณเหมือน
เดิมนะคะ
ทำไมวันนี้กูฟ้ายิ้มบางๆค่ะ
เยอะมากๆเลย
คายิมเขาแล้วมีความสุขค่ะ
มีความสุข
เดี๋ยวนะมีความสุขที่ได้มาเจอนักเรียนหรอ
คะ
ใช่ค่ะก็ใช้เวลาหน้าคนเนี่ยถ้าเป็นอีโมจิ
อะเห็นแบบนี้ก็คือมีความสุข
[เพลง]
หมอเหมือนครูฟ้าไม่ตอนนี้ครูฟ้ามีความสุข
ยิ้มบางๆนะคะมีความสุขมากค่ะทำไมอ่ะคะ
ทำไมครูฟ้าวันนี้มีความสุขมากๆ
เพราะว่ากูฟ้าได้กินชานมไข่มุกค่ะ
ขอดู
ไหนคะไหนๆชานมไข่มุก
ชานมไข่มุกรู้จักไหม
รู้จักรู้จักนักเรียนน่าจะรู้จักไว้ชานม
ไข่มุกชานมไข่มุกเนอะสีดำอันนี้นะคะไข่
มุก
ไข่มุกค่ะน้องหมดนกคา
ร์ครูฟ้าโช้คกินชานมไข่มีมุกเหรอคะ
กินเหรอข้างพาชอบกินชานมไข่มุกมากๆหรือ
อร่อยนะตัวเอง
อร่อยมากอ้ะกินแล้วอ่ะ
มีความสุขมากๆเพราะครูฟ้าได้กินชานมไข่
มุกหน้าครูฟ้าก็จะเปลี่ยนเหมือนอิโมจิ
หน้าครูฟ้าก็จะมีความสุขมากๆ
มีความสุขมากๆค่ะ
โทรหาเนี่ยชอบกินชานมใช่ไหมเขียวอ่ะ
ยังพูดไม่ได้นะคะรอกูฟ้าเคี้ยวเขียวไข่
มุกให้เสร็จก่อน
อร่อย
อร่อยมากค่ะขนมอ่ะทั่วประเทศนักเรียนมี
มั้ยไม่รู้นะแต่ประเทศไทยประเทศไทยมีทานม
ไข่มุกเยอะมากๆๆ
มีหลายแบรนด์หลายแบรนด์เลยอ่าฝาก็ชอบชอบ
กินว่าค่ะพอได้กินชานมไข่มุกครูฟ้าก็มี
ความสุขมากๆ
ให้หามีความสุขลาเรามีความสุขเราก็ยิ้ม
ยี่ห้าให้ยิ้มหายิ้มนะอ้ายิ้มผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเห็นครูฟ้าเนี่ยยิ้มมากๆตั้งแต่เจอ
กันในชั่วโมงคุยกับไอ้ทำไมหน้าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยฮิมมากๆแต่พอไม่ต้องต้องคิดว่าครู
ฟ้าต้องมีความสุขสวยต้องมีความสุขแน่ๆเลย
ไทย 5 และมีความสุขเพราะว่าได้กินชานมไข่
มุก
อร่อยห่าๆแปลว่าเวลาที่ groupon เนี่ยได้
กินชานมไข่มุกก็ทำให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีความ
สุขใช่ไหมคะใส่หักกุมภาก็เลยเวลากูฟ้าแบบ
ว่าอากาศนอนใช่ไหมประเทศไทยเนี่ยอากาศ
ร้อนเหนื่อยพระอากาศร้อนเนี่ยฮะโอเคกี่
องศาเซลเซียสนะคะครูฟ้าร้อนเนี่ยประเทศ
ไทยนะ
35 องศาเซลเซียส
ร้อน
ทำอะไรดี
กินชานมไข่มุกนะ
พี่ Center มาเนี่ย
เวลาที่อากาศร้อน
35 องศา
เขาเรียกเนี่ยร้อนหน้าครูฟ้าใช่ไหมหน้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีความสุข
ไม่มีความสนไม่มีความสุขแต่พอครูฟ้าได้
กินชานมไข่มุก
หน้าโรงฟ้าก็มีความสุขให้ข้างก็เลยต้อง
กินชานมไข่มุกทุกวันเนื้อ
เพลงก็ได้มั้ย
ว่ามันจะทำให้เรามีความสุข
มีฟ้าเนี่ยดื่มชานมหรือว่ากินเนาะกินชานม
ไข่มุกเนี่ยมีความสุขความสุขแล้วมีอย่าง
อื่นอีกไหมอ่ะคะที่ที่ทำให้ครูฟ้ามีความ
สุขถ้าไม่อยากกินชานมไข่ไหม
ถ้าไม่ได้กินชานมไข่มุกเหรอแล้วจะเป็น
ร้องเพลงแน่ๆคุณนี่มีไหมกูคือเลเล่
นี่ขอดูเลขครูฟ้าได้ไหมคะ
โครงฟ้าบอกว่านี่นี่
ชาร์จเสียงเชียร์นะ
[เพลง]
นะคะ
อากาศร้อนๆนะแล้วก็ไม่มีความสุขเลยทำอะไร
ดีไม่มีความฉัน
ก็ต้องไปหยิบคูเลเล่มาแล้วก็เล่นด้วยหรอ
อ่าแล้วก็ร้องเพลง
ค่ะเริ่มแล้วก็จะยิ้มมีความสุขฟังว่าอะไร
ผู้แปลว่าครูฟ้าแน่เวลากินชานมไข่มุกมี
ความสุข
เล่นอูคูเลเล่ก็มีความสุข
ร้องเพลงสมัครร้องเพลง
ก็มีความสุขค่ะคำให้ครูฟ้ามีความสุขใช่หา
แล้วครูหญิงมีไหมคะอะไรทำให้ครูหญิงมี
ความสุขที่ละอันที่ 1 นะเหมือนครูฟ้าเลย
ก็คือกินชานมไข่มุกเหรอไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่ชานมไข่มุกการแทนเวลากินช็อกโกแลตเขา
ก็แล้ว
จบอยากกิน
เวลาที่ได้กินให้เวลามีช็อกโกแลตแล้วก็
คือหญิงเนี่ยโอ้โหแกะช็อกโกแลตออกมาใช่
ไหมคะข้างในเนี่ย
ถ้าไม่เจอช็อกโกแลต
แล้วก็แกะออกใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าเราก็ V
ช็อกโกแลตงานช็อกโกแลตแล้วก็
ช็อกโกแลตแล้วก็คือไม่กินให้ดูนะเดี๋ยว
พูดไม่ได้เก็บ
[เพลง]
มีความสุขมากๆ
กูพาอยากกินช็อกโกแลตมากค่ะเพราะผู้หญิง
โชยอ่ะ
ชานมไข่มุกไม่เอาแล้ว
ผู้หญิงให้ครูฟ้า 1 ชิ้นค่ะ
ออนไลน์นะจะได้มีความสุขเหมือนกันเธอว่า
กินเวลากินช็อกโกแลตเนี่ยก็คิดว่ามีความ
สุขใช่ไหม
คิดว่าน้องคิดว่านักเรียนก็เหมือนเราเวลา
ได้กินกินอะไรที่ชอบเนี่ยทำให้เรามีความ
สุข
ผู้ชายหน้าแบบนี้เลยใช่ไหมคะมีความสุขออก
เอาไม่มีความสุขต่อไปมีความสุข
ดีความสุขก็จะยิ้มมากๆๆ
ได้กินอะไรกินอะไรที่เราชอบก็มีความสุข
ไหมครูบาสเนี่ยกินชานมไข่มุกมีความสุขและ
ผู้หญิงกินช็อกโกแลตมีความสุขหญิงค่ะแล้ว
มีอะไรอีกไหมคะที่ทำให้ครูหญิงมีความสุข
คิดว่าคิดว่าอุ้ยไม่ได้เอาหนังสือมาอ่าน
หนังสือ
โง่อ่านหนังสือหรอค้ามีเป็นหนังสือใช่ไหม
ทรายค่ะอันหนังสือหรืออันนี้คือหนังสือ
เออ
งานครูหญิงชอบอ่านหนังสือหรอคะชายค่ะแต่
ต้องชอบคุยชอบ
ตัวหนังสือแบบ Harry  Potter ไม่เป็นเร็ว
อย่างเงี้ยเวลาอ่านใช่ไหมหูสนุกทำไมอยาก
รู้อยากรู้ต้องแบบอ่านหนังสือก็มีความสุข
มากๆ
ให้เนาะดีนะดีมีอะไรสื่อน้องใหญ่อ้ะครู
ฟ้ากินชานมไข่มุกหญิงกินช็อกโกแลตครูฟ้า
เล่นอูคูเลเล่เอ้เล่
ผู้หญิงอ่านหนังสือมีความสุขมีเย้หน้าเรา
สองคนก็จะเป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะมีความสุขแต่
ว่ามีคำถามแล้วมีอะไรไหมพี่ครูฟ้าทำแล้ว
ไม่มีความสุข
นอกจากห้องพัก
ร้อนเนี่ยไม่มีความสุขก็มีหาไฟล์คิดว่ากู
มาทำวันนี้แล้วไม่มีความสุข
ทำอะไรคะคือทุกคนเนี่ยต้องกินข้าวใช่ไหม
คะกินข้าว
กินข้าวพอกินข้าว
หมดเราก็จะมีจานใช่มั้ย
การลานโอเค
เหมือนจานไหมคะ
อะไรฮะ
อันนี้ก็ได้โอเคมีอายุทานแล้ว
เราก็มีช้อนใช่มั้ยมีซ้อนนะเราต้องพี่ส้ม
ไปอาจจะมีถ้วยในจานช่วยช้อนส้อมเวลากิน
ข้าวเสร็จแล้วที่นี่กันจะมีอาหารไม่มี
อาหารนิดหน่อยอ่า
กินข้าวเสร็จแล้วก็จะมีจานใช่ไหมคะลองทำ
จะ
เอาจานไปล้าง
ล้างจานค่ะดูคอนหลังจารใช่มั้ยมีสไลนะของ
ประเทศไทยสไลด์
ใส่แล้วก็มีฟองน้ำเอ่อแล้วก็
ล้างจาน
ไม่มีความสุขเลยผู้หญิงเวลาอยู่ที่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมคุณแม่บอกครูฟ้ากินข้าวเสร็จแล้วไป
ล้างจานนะ
ไม่อยากรั้งจาณา
บางจาน
ไม่มีความสุขเลยค่ะหน้าหน้าหน้าของทรูฟ้า
ใช้เวลาครูฟ้าล้างจานเนี่ย
นานของทรูฟ้า
ไม่มีความสุขไม่มีความสุขเลยแต่ถ้าหน้า
ของครูฟ้าเวลากินชานมไข่มุกก็
มีความสุขมากๆ
คุณแม่ก็อาจจะอ่ะป๊าไปล้างจานค่ะคุณแม่
เอาชานมไข่มุกให้กินด้วย
ล้างจานแล้วก็ชานมไข่มุกนะ
อ๋อแปลว่าเวลาครูฟ้าล้างชาเนี่ยไม่มีความ
สุขไม่มีความสุขชายแล้วก็อะไร
[เพลง]
38 องศาเซลเซียส
ไม่มีความ
ร้อนมาก
ที่ 5 กุมภาเนี่ยท่ออากาศนะเอาล่ะอากาศ
นึงกูป่าวเนี่ยชอบอากาศร้อนไม่โอเค
บ้านทวิทความสุขใช่ร้านอาหารจะมีอากาศ
หนาวก็มีสโนว์แมน
สโนว์ไวท์ old  know
ลูกข่าวสุขเออ
ต่อว่าถ้าเป็นอากาศร้อนเนี่ย 38 องศาน
มั้ย
ไม่มีความสุขเลยค่ะ
ไม่โอเคเหมือนๆล้างจานไม่เวลากูฟ้าล้าง
จานก็ไม่มีความสุขให้มีความสุขอากาศร้อน
ก็ไม่มีความสุขไม่มีความสุขค่ะง
แต่
เวลามีเสื้อใช่ไหมเราใส่แล้วเนี่ย 1 วัน
แล้วก็
เด่นอ้าใช่มั้ยต้องซักสมัยซักซักซักๆ
เสื้อผ้า
เพราะว่าไม่ชอบไม่ชอบซักเสื้อผ้า
เป็นขี้เกียจอ้าเวลาเห็นเนาะวันนี้มี
เสื้อผ้าเยอะๆผู้หญิงต้องซักเสื้อผ้าก็จะ
ไม่มีความสุขไม่อยากจะเสื้อผ้าแต่ไม่ซัก
ก็ไม่ได้สมัยเสื้อผ้าต้องซัก
ใช่เสื้อผ้าต้องซักถามโง่เหนื่อยมากหนึ่ง
จะบางคนบางคนอาจจะชอบซักเสื้อผ้า
มีความสุขไงอ่ะ
The  Fast ไม่ชอบล้างจานอันนี้ไม่ชอบแต่
ซักเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยชอบค่ะแต่ว่าผู้หญิง
เนี่ยซักเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยนี่ไม่มีความสุขแต่
ครูฟ้าซักเสื้อผ้ามีความสุขมีความสุขค่ะ
ผู้ 5 เวลาเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยใส่แล้วใช่ไหมเรา
เอ้อหือหนูเห็น
แล้วเราก็เอาเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยไปทรัพย์ใช่ไหม
ค่ะก็จะมีเครื่องเป็น Machine ค่ะ
ชีนเครื่องซักผ้าแหงแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะคุณลูก
ค้าใส่ค่ะแบบไหนก็ได้เนาะนี่เนาะเป็น
เครื่องซักผ้าสมัยเปิดและก็เอาเสื้อผ้า
ใส่ลงไป
ครูขามีเครื่องซักผ้าซักผ้าสุราใส่
เครื่องซักผ้าเนี่ยก็จะต้องมีอ่าเลขแฟ๊บ
อ่ะหาก็อาบน้ำแปปแชะใส่แล้วบ่พาคิดว่านะ
เวลาเราซักผ้าเนี่ยเสื้อผ้าแล้วจะหอม
งูน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มดีค่ะบอกให้ดู
เวลาที่ครูฟ้าซักผ้าเวลาคุณฟ้าใช้เครื่อง
ซักผ้าซักผ้าใช้เครื่องซักผ้าซักผ้า
แล้วก็มีเนี้ยน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มอ่ะต่อใส่
ลงไปในเครื่องซักผ้า
ใช่ฮะโอ้โห
มากมัน
หอมต่อการ์ดปลาดมน้ำยาเนี่ย
ยังไม่ได้แกะมันเป็นค่าดม
ของอ๋อ
ชอบมากชอบซักผ้า
ก็บอกฟ้าก็เลยมีความสุขเวลาที่ซักผ้า
เพราะว่ามันมีกลิ่นหอมของน้ำยาซักผ้าใช่
ไหมคะใช่ห่าแล้วก็โอวันนี้เราจะใช้น้ำยา
ปรับผ้านุ่มอะไรนะฮะฝันเห็นมียาปรับผ้า
นุ่มนะน้ำยาปรับผ้านุ่มน้ำยาน้ำยาแนวยาว
อย่าเยอะๆอะไรกินซักผ้าเนี่ยวันนี้ใช้น้ำ
ยาปรับผ้านุ่มอะไรกลิ่นอะไรเออ
เลือกเลือกมีความสุขค่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงน่า
จะบอกว่าไม่มีความสุขช่วยแบบแรกตัดถ้า
เพราะว่าที่บ้านไม่มีเครื่องซักผ้า
จริงเหรอ
ต้องลง
ๆไปข้างล่างใช้เวลาจะไปเสื้อผ้าเยอะๆ
เนี่ยน่ะแล้วพี่คะแล้วก็ลงๆลูกลงเพราะว่า
ครูหญิงไม่ได้อยู่บ้านจะอยู่คอนโดมิเนียม
เวลาจะมีเสื้อผ้าเยอะๆแล้วก็เดินลงไป
เนี่ยก็เลยหรอป่ะไม่ชอบแล้วไม่มีความสุข
เลยเวลาซักผ้าแต่ครูฟ้ามีความสุขมากๆไป
ล้างซักผ้า
สุขมากค่ะชอบซักผ้าแต่ไม่ชอบ
ปากผ้า
เวลาซักเสร็จแล้วใช้เวลาที่ที่เราซักผ้า
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยมันก็จะมีมีต้นเสาแบบนี้
ใช่ไหมคะไทยคุยแล้วก็จะมีไม้แล้วก็คือฟ้า
เนี่ยก็ต้องเอาเสื้อเนี่ยไปตากไว้ก็สะบัด
สะบัดสะบัดก็
R  R เสื้อผ้าตากผ้านะปากพาไม่ชอบปากถ้า
เวลาซักผ้าครูฟ้านะลูกดีความสุขมากๆแต่
สัตว์ถ้าเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้าจะเอาผ้าไปตากน้ำ
ตากผ้า
ไม่มีความสุข
ผู้หญิงโชค
ไม่หญิงตากถ้าความสุข
ไม่อยากผู้หญิงทำไมไม่มันเหมือนกับเวลา
ที่เวลาที่เราตากผ้าใช่ไหมเหมือนเราโฟกัส
ที่อะไรหนึ่งอย่างอ่ะเราก็หยิบมาแล้วก็
ใส่แล้วก็ตากหยิบเสื้อใช่ไหมไสไม้นกไม้
แขวนเสื้ออ่ะแล้วก็ตากรู้สึกแบบไม่ต้อง
เดินไม่ต้องถือน้ำหนักจากเงินก็เลยคิดผู้
หญิงก็มีความสุขนะเวลาที่ได้ถักผ้าๆ
ดีแล้วเดี๋ยวครูฟ้าซักผ้าใช่มั้ยเรา
สองคนก็อยู่ด้วยกันได้เลยเพราะว่า
ครูฟ้ามีความสุขเวลาซักผ้าผู้หญิงไม่มี
ความสุขเวลาซักผ้า
ครูฟ้าไม่มีความสุขเวลาตากผ้าผู้หญิงมี
ความสุขเวลาตากค่าโอเคแท็กคิวสักทีมาอยู่
ด้วยกันได้นะทรายเองแต่ว่าเราก็ไม่รู้
น้องว่านักเรียนเนี่ยนักเรียนนี่มีความ
สุขใช่ไหมมีความสุขเหมือนได้ฟ้า
นะมีความสุข
นักเรียนมีความสุขเวลามีคำอะไร
ใช่นะมีคนเม้นบอกเราได้ใช่ไหมใส่ค่ะหนัง
บอกเราได้นะคะว่ามีความสุขใช้เวลาทำอะไร
หรือว่าไม่มีความสุขใช้เวลาทำอะไร
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นอนโอเคแต่ว่าวันนี้
เราสองคนไปก่อนแล้วเปิดเวลาแล้วนะฮะเวลา
แรงใช่ค่ะก่อนไปนะคะอย่าลืมกด like กด
Share กด Subscribe นั้นว่ากฎ
Notification ไว้ด้วยค่ะเป็นไปมีกิ๊ก
มาเรียนก็จะได้มีคลิปมาแล้วได้ชัดหน้า
จ่ายวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะแล้วเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะนี่ค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ